INTRODUCTION: The
following content
is provided by MIT
OpenCourseWare under a Creative
Commons license.
Additional information
about our license
and MIT OpenCourseWare
in general
is available at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Should we go?
Great.
Well I hope you
enjoyed Patriots' Day,
and now we'll go for the
final weeks of the course.
And I wanted start
with just a thought
about scientific computing,
and the people who work in it,
and the problems.
So just sort of an orientation.
And maybe my point is that
in part of the subject,
the situation started like,
just give me the matrix,
tell me the equation.
I don't want to know
the physics behind it,
just the form of the
equation, and I'll
discuss how it could be solved.
And to contrast that
with what you may often
be meeting in your
theses, even in projects,
where the details, the physical
consequences, the actual detail
behavior of this solution
is what you're looking for.
So somehow there are those
two parts of the world,
and people who know,
understand the physical problem
are on the second side.
And people who maybe
think just about matrices,
like that matrix for example
-- that saddle point matrix,
are more on the first side.
Like, just give me the
matrix and I'll figure out
how to solve the linear system.
If it's a large
linear system, I'll
invent preconditioners,
study stability,
whatever you have to do.
But today's lecture is
kind of half and half,
because that is the
framework that we're in.
But the problem comes from
a real problem in fluids.
And it's called the Stokes
problem, not Navier-Stokes.
So Stokes alone is dealing with
this question when there is
a diffusion term -- and I've
normalized the coefficient
there, viscosity term,
whatever we call it, to be 1 --
and there is the constraint
of incompressibility,
constant pressure,
divergence p equals 0.
I'm sorry not constant,
divergence of p
equals 0 is a constraint.
First, let's just,
so, make some comment
on the physical side
of this equation.
What we're missing, that
Navier-Stokes would put in,
is a convection term.
A term of v dot grad v that
takes account of the fact
that there's a flow
here, things are moving.
We're not in a
stationary situation.
And that term has been dropped.
So that's telling us
then we are in the case
of very, very slow flow, where
that term could be neglected.
And certainly neglecting that
term makes our problem easier.
It leaves us with
this symmetric matrix.
It doesn't make it
totally easy as we'll see,
but it's a lot easier than
when the convection term --
which by the way is not
symmetric and pushes us outside
this framework.
If that's present, then -- of
course in computational fluid
dynamics, that's the
central problem --
you have to deal with it.
So we're taking a
model problem that
doesn't have the
convection, doesn't have
that unsymmetric complexity.
But actually, it's become
more and more important.
It's more than a
model problem now,
because there are a lot of
medical application, say --
probably the flow of your
blood pushed by the heart,
that's moving along
at a decent rate.
But flow into tiny
capillaries is slow,
and Stokes is a reasonable step.
And then actually,
Stokes is also
going to appear in
Navier-Stokes calculations,
because often when you have
two difficult processes
you do a kind of
splitting method,
and you drop one
term for half a step.
So you take for
example, a Stokes step,
and then you do what the
fluid forces you to do.
You move that process
with the flow.
OK.
So we're flowing slowly here.
And the nice thing is that
this fits our saddle point
framework, that's why I'm
calling this block matrix S.
And you see that really, it
came from a minimization.
The minimization
was the problem that
leads to the Laplacian,
that stands for the Laplace
operator, with a minus sign
to make it positive definite.
And then this
constraint gets imposed
by a Lagrange multiplier p.
So p is the Lagrange
multiplier here.
Oh, wrong.
Divergence v is
0, incompressible.
Now, that's on the tape.
It's now on the tape.
Right.
Divergence v is 0.
OK.
So you remember how
our equations looked?
I'm going to write
the unknowns here,
v and p, so that you
see what everything is,
and it equals f and 0.
OK.
So this is now S,
so I chop off here.
So there you see the equation
in the saddle point form.
So A is the gradient,
and it operates on p.
And so p is a scalar.
I better say -- if I
put a little arrow here,
v is a vector, it has
to components say,
if we're in a 2D problem;
f has two components.
p, the Lagrange multiplier for
this constraint, the constraint
is just a scalar constraint,
the divergence is 0.
You remember what divergence
means: dv_1/dx plus dv_2/dy,
so those are the two
components of v, the vector.
And its divergence is 0.
And these are, well
with the minus sign,
are adjoints to each other.
OK.
So what's new that makes this
problem worth some study?
I guess that up to now, we've
taken problems like this
and we've done elimination
to get to a single equation.
You remember that.
So that single equation is A
transpose C*A -- let's see.
We're multiplying that row by
A transpose C and subtracting.
Let me do the
elimination under here.
I multiply the first equation
by A transpose C. You see,
I'm doing the "just give me
the matrix" mode for now.
I multiply by A transpose
C and I subtract.
So the first equation
is still there,
C inverse v plus A*p is f.
But the second equation, now,
when I multiply by A transpose
C, so I just put it up
there, and subtract,
that produces a 0 there, it
produces minus A transpose
C*A*p equals minus
A transpose C*f.
It leads us to this
crucial matrix.
And in applications up to
now, that was the way to go.
That was totally satisfactory.
We eliminated v, we got an
equation for p, we solved it,
and then once we knew p we
went back and found v. OK.
So why is this different?
Why don't I want to
get to A transpose C*A,
the stiffness matrix, if
we were in finite elements.
Why do I want to stay with
this two-field system?
Which in finite
elements is going
to be a mixed method
of finite elements.
I'm going to keep v and p in
the problem for a simple reason,
that C in this
problem is awkward,
C would be the inverse
of the Laplacian.
C is the inverse
of the Laplacian d
second by dx square plus
d second by dy square.
That's what delta stands for.
And that's an
uncomfortable operator
to work with, the inverse here.
In matrix language,
when we discretize,
it won't be sparse, right?
The Laplacian is sparse,
the Laplacian gives us
the five-point matrix,
the matrix with five
non-0's on every row -- four
on the diagonal and four minus
1's, that matrix that
we know, the K2D matrix.
But this is its inverse,
C is now its inverse.
It's the inverse of that
matrix K2D that we've studied,
and of course it's full.
So taking this step produces a
completely full matrix, and all
of our efficient algorithms
for large problems
were for sparse matrices.
Whereas this one is sparse.
I mean this the Laplacian.
So we have the five-point
matrix sitting here.
Here we have a
discrete gradient,
and a discrete divergence.
They're all derivatives, and
you think of the derivatives
as being replaced
by differences.
All these matrices
are sparse, but if we
take that fatal step of
eliminating to get here,
the matrix is full.
Because of this fact that the
inverse of a sparse matrix
tends to be a full matrix.
And you don't want
to work with that.
So we don't want,
that's my message,
don't want A transpose A
when this is not sparse.
OK.
So that's the point
about this example, which
in the notes on the website
is the section called
the saddle point Stokes problem.
OK.
All right.
So now we have both
a specific example
of this Stokes equations,
three equations
really, because this is two
equations for v_1 and v_2,
and this is the third
equation, the constraint.
OK.
So we have both a specific
example and the general case
of --
So we're now going to work
with that matrix as a whole;
we're not going to reduce
it to A transpose C,
although in principle we could.
And the question is
one of stability.
So like, stability
is a question that
didn't come up for
our minimum principles
when there were no constraints.
And maybe I'll just put
a little mention why.
So this is the first
time we've had to face
the question of stability.
What do I mean that S
inverse is under control?
I don't mean that
it's easy to compute,
the inverse of
that block matrix.
But I have to know that
the matrix is invertible.
And stability is always
like one slight step
more than just being invertible.
It means it's
invertible and you have
some control of the inverse.
You know, it's not just
on the verge of disaster.
So we want to know about
the inverse of that matrix.
That's essentially it, we
want to know about the inverse
of that matrix.
And in the process,
we really want
to know about the
inverse of this matrix.
So we may not want to compute
it, that was my point,
but stability is telling
us -- we have here a matrix
that's not positive definite.
That the key issue here.
Our saddle point matrix
is not positive definite.
It has positive eigenvalues
and negative eigenvalues.
Let me just take some examples.
OK.
So here's an S. So I have
a positive thing there.
Nonzero stuff there.
There is the simplest
example I could think of.
That matrix is not
positive definite.
It's determinant is
minus 1, actually.
But its eigenvalues are, I mean,
they're safely away from 0.
it's not singular or
close to singular either.
So that two by two
example, no problem.
This equation -- well, I could
study the invertibility of this
particular matrix, that would be
solving differential equations.
In other words, I
could study the case --
are p and v under control
if I have a bound on f?
Well, they are.
But the issue comes when
I go to finite elements,
when I look at a subspace.
So have to try to
make that clear.
What I plan to do to
solve a continuous problem
is to discretize it.
This is my continuous matrix,
block matrix, symbolic
of the differential equations.
And it's OK, analysis
would show that.
But the question is:
if I approximate v
by some combination of finite
elements, let me call it v_h.
If I approximate the pressure
by some pressure element p_h,
then I'm sort of
projecting the problem down
into these finite-dimensional,
finite element subspaces.
And of course f will get
projected down to f_h.
And the matrices,
these operators,
will turn into finite
sparse matrices.
And the question is
that projection safe?
So that's really it.
It's the stability.
S inverse is under
control, this is OK.
But is the projection of
S inverse under control?
Is the projection of S
-- so if I project it,
is the inverse of
that under control?
That's the question.
And this projection is --
what comes up in applications,
this is a projection of
the continuous problem,
the differential equation,
onto finite element spaces,
finite element trial function.
OK.
So we've spoken a little about
finite elements in this course,
and more in 18.085,
and you're probably
have seen them elsewhere.
You know that we can approximate
velocities by -- well,
here would be a really
important example,
because it's an especially
simple finite elements.
If I take my region, suppose it
happened to be that rectangle,
I divide that rectangle
into small squares,
there's a small square.
I'm using squares
rather than triangles.
And in each square I make
some low-degree approximation,
low-degree trial function,
for the velocities
and the pressures.
And the question is what
functions can I use?
For example, one I would love
to be able to use would be,
so in each square
I would like to be
able to use piecewise
constant pressures.
Piecewise constant pressure,
so p_h equal constant
in each element.
Element is the square.
So a different constant
in each element.
So that would give me
my vector of p_h's.
There would be one component
for every little square.
And now what about v_h?
What trial function would I
like to use for the velocities?
Constant velocities
wouldn't be good,
that's further than
I'm willing to go.
I'll go piecewise
linear in each square.
Now piecewise linear in each
triangle meant that it had
the form a plus b*x plus c*y.
Strictly speaking
that's what I should
mean by piecewise linear, with
a different coefficient a, b,
c in each piece.
But because we're
in squares now,
we've got four nodal values, and
we want a fourth coefficient.
This was appropriate
on triangles,
on a square we really include
the bilinear term d*x*y.
OK.
So we have four
coefficients which
determine and can be
determined from the four
values of the node.
You see that I'm
describing the whole space.
Now I cut the region
into more squares,
and I've described a way of
discretizing the differential
difference equation.
The weak form of
continuous problem,
when I plug in these
functions, would give me
a matrix problem,
a discrete problem,
that will have this form.
And the question is
do I have any control?
So it will give me this
projected matrix now,
finite-dimensional instead
of a continuous problem.
And the question is: have
I still got any control?
Well the answer for this
particular choice of pressure
space and velocity space is no.
Unfortunately the matrix
S that appears instead,
the C inverse h,
shall I say, it would
be like our K2D
inverse, that was pretty
close of what it would be.
And the A_h and the A
transpose h and the 0.
That matrix has a
famous null vector
for this specific example.
I'm taking big jumps
here, because I just
want to say the main point.
The main point here
is that a null vector
appears in this problem.
S fails to be invertible, and
that null vector is like --
finite element
people know its name.
It has a couple of names
actually, maybe checkerboard.
The null vector is a vector when
the pressure is 1, minus 1, 1,
minus 1 in a checkerboard
pattern over the whole region,
and a corresponding velocity.
Well, the trouble is
A_h times this p is 0.
That's what kills you.
It turns out that A times
that particular pressure is 0.
And if you lose
control of A that way,
you've lost control
A transpose CA.
You've lost everything.
So I guess, coming back
to my opening comments.
Here's a case in which we
have a physical problem,
but it falls into a pattern,
where the mathematics actually
decides, are we able to
use the trial spaces that
are most convenient?
I say convenient rather than
most accurate of course.
If I wanted to
improve the accuracy,
I would go up in
the degree, I would
take pressures to be piecewise
linear and velocities
to be piecewise quadratic
with more points.
And I could check
the stability or not,
is the matrix invertible
or not, and the answer
might be better there.
In fact the notes and any book
on finite elements has a list.
And I don't plan on
making that list here.
But it has a list of pressure
spaces, pressure elements
and velocity elements, on
which the first guy that I've
mentioned would be
like Q of 0, degree 0.
and velocities Q_1
degree 1, and the letter
Q being used for quadrilateral.
If I divided it into triangles,
I would use the letter P
for polynomial in that case.
And this is a fail.
This one fails.
And then another list would
be how about Q_1, Q_1?
I don't know.
I wouldn't bet much on
Q_1, Q_1, and of course I
can look at the notes
to see what the answer.
Or Q_1, Q_2 that's probably
got a better chance.
Or many, many -- you know,
people are inventing finite
elements all the time, and
they're having to check
the stability or not, the
uniform invertibility or not
of S. OK.
I just want to say that this one
is so attractive, because it's
so simple that people
don't give up on it.
They want to go with this,
this is a fail, but --
so stabilize it.
That one is so attractive.
And you know specifically that
it's this checkerboard mode
that's in the null
space, so you just
think, how am I going to get
that mode out of the null?
And the stabilizing method
is you stick a matrix here
for purely numerical
reasons, and it'll
be a matrix that exactly has
this checkerboard pattern, so
that the checkerboard is not
any longer in the null space.
Maybe I call it minus some small
number times some E matrix,
it's often written E. And alpha
you keep as small as you dare.
But the effect is that it takes
this checkerboard pressure out
of the null space.
You see the problem was that
without that, the columns of A
were not independent.
A times P could be 0.
And if those columns are not
independent, you're lost.
Let me put the 0 back.
Why was that a bad thing?
I want to now sort of connect
it to the matrix theory.
If I have this particular
pressure and A_h*p is 0,
so that tells me that those
columns of A_h are dependent.
Then the columns of S
are dependent, right.
If I have something in
the null space of A_h,
then I just put -- a
pressure, this pressure,
in the null space of A_h -- then
I just take the v to be there
0, then these guys
don't do anything.
And that A times that bad
pressure gives 0, so I have
(v, p), a velocity, pressure,
that's in the null space.
OK.
So the way it gets fixed is to
stick in some small stabilizing
factor there.
OK.
All right.
Now, that's the specifics
of this particular example.
Well, I didn't give
all the specifics.
If I were really on the
ball I would show in detail
why that checkerboard appears
and kills this choice.
I would check each of
these other choices,
and beside each one I
would put fail or success.
And when it fails, I would try
to identify the failure mode,
so that if you wanted you
could stabilize and get
rid of that failure mode.
OK.
What I'll do instead is to come
to the general question here.
So the general question is
to deal with this matrix,
S. Can I write it again?
C inverse, A; A transpose, 0.
I want to look it its
-- is it invertible?
Can I get some bound
on its inverse?
What do I have to know?
And I'll just emphasize here,
what's the real problem?
Because we saw it right there.
The real problem is if the
columns of A are dependent.
In other words,
i.e., in other words,
A*p equals 0 has a
nonzero solution.
Then you're wiped out.
I'll just repeat.
If the columns of
A are dependent,
then the columns
of S are dependent,
the matrix is singular,
and you're finished.
So somehow, we have to
get some muscle behind A.
But remember, A is a
rectangular matrix.
This C is m by m,
this A that comes up
in the constraint is m by n.
It has, we hope, more
rows than columns.
But still, the columns
could be dependent,
and in this situation they are.
OK.
So the question is, we have
to get some muscle behind A.
And this is the famous condition
so called inf-sup condition
that you would find in Professor
Bathe's finite element book.
But maybe these notes kind of
focus on the heart of the idea.
And again, in some
way it's conditioned
on A really, and on the pressure
spaces and the velocity spaces
that you choose.
OK.
So these, you could really
say are A_h, p_h, and v_h,
but I'll skip writing
h's on everything now.
So I'm down in
the discrete case,
but I have a sequence
of discrete problem
which are growing
as h gets smaller,
and the question is do I have
a fixed beta that control this?
And it turns out that this
is the requirement that --
this inf-sup condition says
that for every pressure,
there is a velocity --
every discrete pressure now,
there is a discrete velocity
such that this holds.
So it's sort of forcing
A to stay away from 0.
This beta is a fixed
number, and this sort of
is the right normalization
that goes with it.
So you see why it's
v transpose A*p?
Because A -- you know, if I
look at the quadratic form,
v transpose p
transpose -- you know,
the quadratic form with the
matrix is always multiply
by a vector here, multiply
by its transpose here,
where is the A term?
A will multiply p, and it'll
be multiplied by v transpose.
In the quadratic
part, in the energy,
is this v transpose A*p.
And that's what we
can't let go to 0.
Because we are not --
if that part fails us,
if we lose these and
we have a 0 there,
this part on the
submatrix can't save us.
Right.
So before I say anything
more about that,
let me just emphasize
what stability
was in the symmetric case.
So suppose I have a positive
definite symmetric matrix.
It's got some eigenvalues,
lambda_1 to lambda_n.
OK.
What you see on
this board is going
to explain why
stability is automatic
if I'm dealing with
positive definite things.
So suppose I project.
I take this matrix -- let me
just project in the most direct
way.
I'll throw away the
last row and column.
Suppose I throw away
the last row and column.
That part is now gone, so
these are the eigenvalues of K.
And of course, being
positive definite,
they're bigger than 0.
OK.
So that was the whole matrix,
but now what I'm going to do
is I'm going to project
on the first n minus 1
rows and columns.
So I'm going to look at the
submatrix K sub n minus 1.
And it has some eigenvalues.
Are they the same as those?
No way.
The eigenvalues of this
submatrix will be --
and you see, I'm not
in this situation,
this was not positive definite.
So I'm looking here at the
positive definite case.
This has some eigenvalues,
say mu_1 up to mu_(n-1).
These will be the eigenvalues
of the submatrix, K_(n-1).
And linear algebra is
just like the right place
to look for some information
on the connection
between the mus and lambdas.
They're certainly not equal.
Our first question is if I
take a positive definite matrix
with positive
eigenvalues, I throw away
the last row and column.
Do I still have a
positive definite?
Is that submatrix
And the answer is yes.
The eigenvalues
are all positive.
And more than that, how about
that smallest eigenvalue?
Because the eigenvalue is
measuring like how close
are we to disaster, to singular.
Can I say anything about
that smallest eigenvalue?
And the answer is yes.
The smallest eigenvalue
of K_(n-1) is never below
the smallest eigenvalue
of the full matrix.
So if the full matrix is
OK, all the projections,
all the subspace, all the
submatrices are even more OK.
And up at the other
end, at the top end,
the top eigenvalue
in the submatrix
never passes the top
eigenvalue in the big matrix.
So you see, at both ends I have
what I want, I have control.
If I have some range of
eigenvalues for the big matrix,
then all its projections
are inside that range.
And therefore the
condition number,
which would be the
ratio of this to this,
is smaller than the condition
number of the whole matrix.
So the condition number of
K_(n-1) is less or equal
the condition number of K_n.
OK.
And that's exactly why working
with positive definite matrices
is so comfortable.
The stability is just automatic.
But here we're not working with
positive definite matrices.
The stability is not
automatic, and we
need this inf-sup condition.
And I don't know whether to try.
Maybe I'm -- I'm a little
hesitant to go through
the steps that lead
from there to there,
because this lecture is
already asking you to put a lot
of things together
without details.
And the notes do
the best job I could
do in making those
steps simple and clear.
And this is what
you actually check.
You check this condition for
any proposed finite element,
and any different problem.
It wouldn't have to
be the Stokes problem.
Other problems would give
us a constraint matrix
A, a sort of stiffness
submatrix C inverse,
and we could check
the condition again.
OK.
So maybe I'm going to leave
that statement for the notes.
OK.
So that's this
inf-sup condition.
And of course, you see right
away that if A had dependent
columns, which is the big risk,
if A had dependent columns,
that would mean that
A*p is 0 for some p.
And then there would be
no v. No v could possibly
be found that would save it.
If A had dependent
columns, that's bogeyman
that we're avoiding above all.
If A had dependent columns,
then there would be a solution
to A*p equals 0, this
left side would be 0,
the right side wouldn't, and the
inf-sup condition would fail.
But the inf-sup
condition tells us, well,
what about if there
are pressures, that --
where A*p get smaller and
smaller as the mesh size
changes, then the question
is can I find a v and so on.
So that's the full
condition, but not
to lose sight of the fact
that the central question,
the key question is the
independence or dependence
of the columns of A. OK.
Good.
So let's see, maybe
that's as much as I
want to say about
the Stokes example,
and what it leads to in
the finite element world.
I guess I'm going to stay
for another lecture or two
with these minimizations.
So maybe I'll just
anticipate slightly
the start of the next lecture.
Because I'm quite pleased
about getting this next topic
into the series of lectures.
Let me say what it is.
So it's going to be a
minimization of an A*u minus b
squared.
OK.
Just as this lecture has
seen, the possibility
comes up that the columns
of A are not independent,
that this problem is in trouble.
So I want to regularize
this problem.
How do I save a
problem in which --
so this is a major application
-- in which A is, say --
maybe A transpose A is the
easiest thing to say --
A transpose A is
nearly singular,
or just plain singular.
I'll say or singular.
How do we rescue the problem?
Because numerically
and theoretically
it's a disaster as it stands.
OK.
It's ill posed.
So let me introduce that
word, ill-posed problem.
And let me mention,
since I'm just
using these last few
minutes as a kind of getting
the big picture, where do
ill-posed problems come from,
where does these
things come from?
They come typically from what
are called inverse problems.
So the application is
to inverse problems.
What's an inverse problem?
An inverse problem is, for
a differential equation,
you know some
inputs and outputs,
you know some solutions, but
you don't know the equation.
You don't know the coefficient.
So you're trying
to determine what
are the material
properties by looking
to see what the outputs are
for experimental inputs.
And very frequently, you don't
have enough inputs to really
determine what these -- so
it's inverse problem to find
the coefficients of the equation
given some information on its
solutions, some measurements.
And of course they're
probably noisy measurements.
I mean this is an enormous
source of applications, growing
in importance, and how
do we deal with it.
Well, you regularize it.
So this is typical of
this type of problem.
You add on some multiples
of something that's safe,
like for example u square.
So the result is, here,
that this A transpose A that
comes from this problem, there's
an alpha times the identity
coming from this problem.
I mean it's an ordinary
least squares problem,
and it leads us to the
matrix A transpose A,
comes from the first part.
But I'm just talking about
the standard normal equations.
It will produce an A
transpose A from here.
But from here it will produce
an alpha times the identity.
And of course, just the
way this minus E worked up
there, here I'm doing
it even more directly,
I'm pushing the
problem away from 0.
This alpha, this parameter and
the choice of that parameter,
is the million dollar question
in this whole subject.
But its purpose is to
regularize the problem,
to take this nearly singular
matrix and push it up.
You have to see, this
matrix, A transpose A,
never has negative eigenvalues,
the problem is 0 or very small,
small positive.
So by adding on alpha*I,
I push those away from 0.
Over there we had the
problem of eigenvalues
being positive or negative,
and by pushing in one direction
we might just bring a negative
eigenvalue right onto 0.
That's not our problem
in this upcoming lecture.
In this upcoming lecture we
know that nothing is negative,
but we need to make
it properly positive.
OK.
So that's what's coming.
Can I just say: the application
that I want to describe
is the first one I've
given in the life sciences,
and I hope not the last.
I don't know if any of you
can suggest -- and if you can,
an email will be very
much appreciated --
applications of this whole
framework in life sciences.
So you'll see a
particular application
of this ill-posed problem
in trying to determine gene
structure from expressions.
OK.
So that's what's coming Friday.
And I realize, here I'm
talking about material
that probably is not going
to go in your projects,
because of the timing.
I'm thinking that
your projects are
more likely to build on
what you had in project one,
and the basic
material about solving
large systems and
basic minimizations.
OK.
Thank you.
See you Friday.